you know who you are you're the Dos
Equis guy oh yeah you're the most
interesting man in the world and we we
act like it's this old uh Hispanic guy
but it's you you lived in England South
America you're you're off in Kenya at
11. there's uh multiple times yeah yeah
you [ __ ] every lady you did every drug
you were on the big screen I mean you've
lived man that's what thank you dude I
like to think that I really truly have
lived they've tested animal products on
you yeah but I've tested drugs on me for
Animals what's the difference ah they
they well I don't know like yeah yeah
what was your favorite all right well
there was only one drug that they tested
on me for use on animals
Ivermectin ah now it's called rack
dopamine hydrochloride oh is that for
raccoons yeah it was to give to pigs and
cows to make them have more muscle and
less fat why wouldn't they do that on
pigs
because the the idea of testing it on
animals was to make the the meat leaner
to appeal to a more health conscious
consumer but if if it were to pan out
then the idea is that people are going
to then eat the meat which means a
minute trace of this drug which lives in
the meat will enter the human body and
anything that comes in contact or goes
into the human body has to First be
tested right so because people would get
a trace of the drug when they ate the
meat they had to do this test to see how
much of the human body how much the
human body could withstand of the
drugs you take uh the the study went on
until someone's resting heart rate went
over 150 beats per minute
all right so was that about a gallon
that's
they uh I'm not I'm not even sure I uh I
can't really remember but um have you
ever looked this drug up since you've
done this like I I don't think it got
cleared I don't think oh wow you're the
wrong guy to test it on because you're
you're a little stronger than most there
were six people in the study and and my
resting heart rate never exactly yeah it
never went over like 90 I don't think
would anybody else like oh my god there
was like one or two dudes were literally
drenched in sweat like having like a
rough time with it and there's only six
people in the world they've tested this
drug on and you were uh in that study I
don't know if they had other studies but
yeah like normally they'll do like the
studies like a lot this was a
particularly dangerous study so they had
a smaller group why didn't you have a
choice the more dangerous to study the
more money you get
and they said okay you could do a couple
different options we have a dangerous
one and you have oh yeah and and uh it
was supposed to be for like 1200 bucks
or something and like they just didn't
get the results they were looking for
they said hey we want to extend the
study and we'll bump it up from 1200
bucks to 2 000 bucks whoa you were like
[ __ ] yeah I mean you called the place
and said how do you get the how do they
put an ad out and then you respond to it
they uh I don't know if it was an ad man
I think it was more like this one guy
had already done it and then and turned
us on to it and we called the place up
and figured it out we drove from
Colorado to Austin Texas to do it just
to do that yeah we used to do the uh the
plasma do you ever do the plasma wow did
you ever blow a load and sell that I
tried they wouldn't take it yeah I've
blown a load but they never yeah they
actually charged me
I tried yeah the if if you're gonna
um blow a load and have it actually be
used for artificial insemination that's
like over the top like what they pay you
by the time you get to the level of
screening and this and that they're
actually going to use it for for a donor
then like it's big money yeah like you
like anybody can go get paid like to for
them to test freezing techniques and
[ __ ] but they're not gonna do well you
gotta we gotta get some little stevos
out there because I feel like you could
you could be like an army of soldiers
that wouldn't go down no I love that but
I'm not interested in and I got a
vasectomy oh but we smart we saved the
sperm because I think you'd be a good
father I think so too you're a good dog
dad that was that was one of my um one
of my bits for the hour I'm touring with
now is the vasectomy Olympics
uh You Can't Get It reversed just saying
yeah that's possible I wouldn't want it
I don't think you don't want a rug Red I
do not why do you I think I'd like a kid
one day yeah I think I'd want a kid too
yeah I'm down yeah just the the world is
an unfriendly place I agree with that
increasingly unfriendly it's called
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on Amazon and type in Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude